hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
häufiges mal wieder etwas türkisches hat
sich wirklich viele meiner zuschauer
auch gewünscht und zwar gibt's auch was
für den murat denn ich mache es mit
brötchen
ihr kennt vielleicht falls immer beim
türkischen bäcker wat da gibt es dieses
image ringe also das sind diese
zusammenhänge und die habe ich jetzt
kombiniert mit einer füllung und das
ganze als brötchen also eigentlich
richtig coole kombination
ich muss jetzt zuerst mal einen hefeteig
herstellen das ist jetzt kein standard
hefeteig da ist noch ein bisschen
schmandt mit dabei und auch backpulver
mit dabei
denn dadurch werden diese brötchen extra
locker und ich will eigentlich ort nicht
sagen flucht aber sie sind echt fluffig
also ich sage jetzt mal ganz christi
zutaten
ich brauche einen würfel hefe ein
teelöffel zucker dreier einen becher
schmand und diesen schwand becher
benutze ich später dann auch als maß ein
becher warmes wasser ein becher olivenöl
ein becher lauwarme milch ein päckchen
backpulver zwei teelöffel salz und 1 2
kilo mehl diesen schwächer als mass
benutzen werde möchte ich den erst mal
aus lernen und fragte ich direkt in
schwand rührschüssel
und dann nehme ich direkt das warme
wasser und füllt es ihnen besser ein
außerdem richtig schön voll und das
wasser vermische ich jetzt erstmal mit
der hitze da kann ich die hefe nämlich
darin gut auflösen
mit dem zucker mit rein könnte hier
wunderschön aufgehen und das vermisse
ich jetzt kurze dass ich die hefe
auflöst
jetzt kann die hefe wasser zucker
mischung direkt mit in die schüssel noch
aus jetzt nehme ich wieder diesen becher
und habe auch bereits etwas milch
erwärmen als er diese wirklich nur
lauwarm
das kann ich jetzt auch direkt damit
abmessen kommt auch gedacht und dann
auch gleich die drei eier backpulver
vermischen jetzt mit dem mehl und gebt
dann schon mal mehr als die hälfte des
mädels mit rein und lassen den tag schon
mal ein bisschen kneten ich mache das
direkt mit ein bisschen hitze dann geht
nämlich der hilfe trägt gleich auch gut
auf und gibt dann auch schon das salz
betreiben
gebe ich immer wieder mail mit rein und
habe jetzt auch schon einen becher
olivenöl abgemessen
der kommt auch mit und dann musst du
viel mehl mit rein das ein schöner
weiter teig entsteht da nicht mehr klebt
und der einfach nicht zu feucht ist also
jetzt kommt einfach darauf an wie groß
die eier an die er verwendet habt wenn
franz großer mehrheit wenn es keiner
erwarten das interesse liegt
den teig habe ich jetzt für etwa sieben
bis acht minuten treten lassen und erst
dann gut wenn er einfach nicht mehr an
den händen klebt so jetzt lese ich ihnen
direkt aus der form heraus gebe ich ein
bisschen mehl auf die arbeitsfläche
jetzt sieht man es auch ganz gut also
der teig ist wirklich noch sehr weich
aber eben nicht mehr klebt ich und dann
ist da eben perfekt jetzt vorm ich ihn
mit den händen zu einer großen kugel
zusammen dafür immer von außen nach
innen kneten
und dann gebe ich ihnen die schüssel
wieder zurück mit etwas mehl decken dann
auch mit etwas mehl ab und dann lasse
ich ihn noch mal für etwa eine halbe
stunde auf gehen bis er sich verdoppelt
hat
der hefeteig gesetzt richtig gut
aufgegangen und ich werde jetzt als
füllung sawtschuk und käse nehmen aber
natürlich könnt ihr bei der füllung zum
beispiel auch eine rein vegetarische
füllung nehmen oder eine ganz andere
führung mittag fleisch zum beispiel oder
mit lauch und käse also da gibt es
wirklich alle möglichen varianten ich
für die füllung brauche ich 200 gramm
käse ich habe zehn kugeln schafskäse
würde auch gehen 250 gramm so job das
netz bereits in scheiben geschnitten
dann brauche ich 100 milliliter wasser
und zwei esslöffel trauben sirup und
etwa 200 gramm sesam ich werde später
wasser und trauben sie gut vermischen
und zwar bringt es eine ganz leichte
süße mit rein also wer sieht schon mal
gegessen hat der weiß dass die so ganz
leicht süßlich schmecken aber es ist
wirklich nicht zu süß als es beißt sich
jetzt nicht mit dem stock und knoblauch
geschmack zuerst einmal bereit ich kurz
die füllung vor und schneit es zu zug in
kleine würfel
den käse zwar kleiner ich ein bisschen
mit einer gabel
und schon für mich einfach kurz käse und
produkt
jetzt kann ich den teig portionieren
dafür nehme ich jetzt erstmal nur die
hälfte und ich mache das immer ganz
gerne so dass ich den teig dann auch
abwägen denn dann sind alle teilchen
gleich groß und ich mache jetzt immer
kleine päckchen mit 80 gramm und formen
die dann zu einer kugel
ich habe jetzt insgesamt 30 welchen
daraus geformt und jetzt nämlich eines
der ersten denn die matte so ein
bisschen ruhen lässt also wenn man alle
formen direkt und sind die ersten wieder
bin ausgeruht und kann man direkt weiter
arbeiten
jetzt hole ich die auch mit etwas mehl
und die müssen jetzt gar nicht so groß
sein
also kratzern durchmesser von etwa zehn
bis zwölf zentimetern und dann kommt
jetzt etwas von der füllung drauf
und dann mache ich die enden hier oben
jetzt zu
da kann ich das jetzt erst mal zur seite
stellen und mache jetzt etwa immer so
vier bis fünf stück und dann bereiche
gleich weiter vor
jetzt vermisse ich zwei esslöffel von
dem trauben sirup mit dem wasser wenn
jetzt kein trauben sirup habt also das
ist schon richtig türkisch aber ihr
könnt ihr zum beispiel auch in anderen
zielgruppen ahornsirup oder so zum
beispiel nehmen und am besten am besten
vermischt sich wenn ihr wenn ihr
lauwarmes wasser nehmen und jetzt nehme
ich immer so ein teilchen und uns
erstmal in den zero s ins wasser dann in
sesam und dann kommt direkt aufs
backblech
die arbeit kann man zum beispiel ganz
gut zu zweit machen das heißt einer
taucht in die flüssigkeit und der andere
dann in zusammen
jetzt schneide ich die oberseite noch
mit einem scharfen messer ein
die teile gehen ja im backofen dann noch
mal richtig gut auf denn ich habe nicht
nur hefe trend sondern auch backpulver
und dann sieht es gleich aus wie so
kleine brötchen
und so werden sie jetzt im vorgeheizten
backofen bei 200 grad ober unterhitze
für etwa 20 minuten gefragt
so jetzt sind die sie mit porta gebacken
und du darfst sie direkt probieren ich
hab sogar abkühlen lassen
ok bitte schön was ich jetzt weiß was
ich jetzt was drin
die sind alle gleich gefühlt alle mit
zuzug und käse also mit zwischen käse
oder butter und käse
dazu haben erst mal ich finde es von der
konsistenz dagegen ja dann meine kamera
zeigen passiert so richtig so nicht hat
gleich richtig weil ich mal papa sein
team
und sag mal in die kamera also ich finde
sich eine ehre für jedes turbines
brötchen zu dürfen - trug ohne käse was
ja auch noch mal unbedingt beachten muss
wenn das hier ist das intel habt danach
vielleicht ein zahnstocher ja also diese
brötchen könnt ihr wie gesagt mit jeder
art von füllung befüllen ob es
vegetarisch oder eben doch mit youtube
oder mit fleisch
ich finde sie richtig toll man kann sie
gut vorbereiten und man kann sie zum
beispiel abends vorbereiten und am
nächsten morgen dann im toaster
aufbacken eingeschätzt die ramsauer zu
machen
ein bisschen ein bisschen mehr drin sein
nicht aber ist die reine geschmackssache
weil mir kann's immer wird er schon hier
kann es auch zu tun mit bisschen
brötchen seien so das ist genau wie
schon gesagt
also falls ihr dieses rezept nach machen
wollt geht auf seine blog de da steht
noch mal ganz genau und ich glaube der
moral ist ganz begeistert als begnadeter
stop liebhaber unser mir kriegt jetzt
auch ihre portionen mit zug ohne käse
und ich es dir gleich mit einer
schönen glas tee also viel spaß beim
nachbacken und wir sehen uns beim
nächsten mal bis dann aber noch kein zug
ok probieren